I already but you know stated my case
with Phil I woulda DQ'd him that's all I
just DQ him if it was somebody of lesser
stature or celebrity they would have
been DQ'd in my opinion I'm not buying
his excuse but I don't think this is
what defines his legacy there Brandel
Chamblee the golf Jim joins us now
Brandl thanks for joining us where do
you stand on all of this well I agree
with you I don't think this will define
his legacy I think he'll go down as one
of the greatest most popular players in
the mystery game but you know this will
certainly be part of his legacy just
like his comments after the 2014 Ryder
Cup given his position in the game I've
never seen anything like this I mean
there's no corresponding video with a
video of Palmer or Hogan or Nancy but
you probably nothing
given his stature in the game it was
bizarre yeah he should have been
disqualified
I didn't think the USGA had a consistent
weekend and as I pointed out to start
the show I can't have four different
golf courses in there were four
different golf courses Randall
absolutely I mean that's embarrassing
it really is another not fair it's in
embarrassing you know they I don't know
what's going on at the USGA to me it's
like they're lacking a clear leadership
they don't have some clear objective on
how to set up a golf it can't be that
difficult to miss it so badly the first
thing respawn the next day mrs. so badly
the third day and it's so easy gone the
fourth day Rickie Fowler 84 on Saturday
65 on Sunday that's a 19 shot disparity
in the history of the US Open there's
never been such a disparity between a
third and fourth round ever
that's 19 shots in the history there's
only been 16 shots there was also
another 16 shots parity between Patrick
Rodgers it's pretty much sums it up when
you shoot 66 on Saturday and you're in
45th place what do you pick up you pick
up four or five shots on the leaders
those guys Tony fee now Daniel Berger
relation 66 they picked up to 11 shots
on the leaders there was nowhere near
the same golf course in the morning
today afternoon the story that we take
away from this is what 10 years down the
road when I say man member when the US
Open was a
Shinnecock and you're gonna say what I'm
gonna say it was a really bad week for
the USTA a really bad week for Phil
Mickelson and then I need to go to the
gym and work out or at least I should
have after looking at Brooks koepka oh
my god you know what I was literally
when I was playing golf that's all I did
was play golf everything day and every
time you go to the gym someone would say
no no no you can't go if you don't go to
gym you're gonna ruin your flexibility
well okay I've come 180 degrees on this
if I had it to do over again yeah I'd be
in the gym every doggone day because if
you if you need another example of how
the game of golf has changed from the
days of Ray Floyd and Corey Pavin then
watching Dustin Johnson and Brooks kepta
play golf yesterday you're you're blind
because the game of golf
you know Tiger Woods came along I really
did think he was kind of more of an end
than a beginning I didn't think people
would fall in line to the extent that
they have but the game has gotten so
physical now and it actually it's
beautiful to watch these these guys are
athlete s today morning before he went
out and played Brooke Skeptical benched
215 times play golf for crying out loud
to swing an 11 ounce club but my god has
power and athleticism become a dominant
part of golf
explain this to me because I'm watching
I haven't played Shinnecock I've been
there I understand how difficult it is
but Pebble Beach next year when they
have the US Open why does Pebble have to
if you're gonna bring it to Pebble why
does Pebble have to be tricked up made
you know I don't want to humiliate you
or even Humble you I want to challenge
you so it's Pebble gonna be like
Shinnecock and they're gonna try to do
all these crazy things to make these
guys you know nobody gets to break par
well you know baseball where you like to
think that if their wits about them and
they won't shave the Greens down to
where they're almost dead
I mean it seems pretty simple to set up
a fair golf course
decide on a fairway with this side on a
penalty for the rough and decide on what
speed of the Greens
is appropriate given the slope to the
condition of the greens it really can't
be any more difficult Matt but they're
hell-bent on shaving the greens and
running green speeds at levels that that
Peter on absurd and if the weather gets
a little cockeyed then the whole thing
goes to hell
so yeah you know you'd think it'd be
easier than it is but no they don't is a
great golf course the problem with you
know look it's ko Ana they're gonna be
on point it's gonna be bumpy and I
played the 92 US Open a pebble I played
in mm open a pedal and the green sort of
all around out there it's part of it
they need to keep them under appropriate
speed they need to have a great setup
brand old safe travels home great to
talk to you this weekend thank you for
joining us thanks so much Dan take care
guys
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]